COLT MCANLIS: Hey everyone,
thank you for your time today.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
Today we're going to talk about
the next five billion gamers.
And I got to tell
you, this is really
an important topic for me.
Because I love video games.
Does anyone else
love video games?
Like you love-- like
it's part of who you are.
Yeah?
Round of applause?
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
And when I mean, I
love video games,
I don't mean I just go home
and I just play video games.
No, I mean I-- video games
molded me as a human being.
Right?
So you've got to understand.
I grew up in the deserts
of Las Vegas, Nevada.
[SOMEONE HOOTS]
One guy.
Nice.
Now while Vegas is a
nice place to visit,
it's a really crummy
place to grow up.
Because as a kid,
there's really nothing
to do except dig
holes in the dirt,
catch lizards, and
really figure out
creative things to
do with sunburn.
Like, that's it.
Right?
For me, video games
were what I did.
They were who I was.
They taught me things.
They educated me.
They let me see how
to solve problems,
that my princess was
always in another castle.
This is me at age 12.
And I put this up
here first off to show
that I did have hair at
one point in my life.
But more importantly,
because this is actually
the most influential picture I
have throughout my entire life.
This is actually
the exact moment--
I had just completed Super
Metroid on the Super Nintendo.
There's my handy Nintendo Power
that helped me through it.
This is the exact
moment that I decided
that I was going to make video
games for the rest of my life.
It was right there.
Right there.
We caught it on camera.
The spark happened.
I said, video games
matter so much to me
that this is all I want to do.
And since then I've been
losing my hair slowly
but we've been doing that.
Now as I've grown up with
video games since that date,
video games have
grown up as well.
So a lot of us, when we
started-- a lot of us
here in my age
group-- sorry, right?
You started out with the
early consoles and arcades.
Anyone remember
putting the quarter
on the arcade, like
I got next dibs.
Round of applause, come on.
We can't see your
hands on the screen.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah.
I remember I almost got into
a fight in an arcade one time
because a dude wasn't
honoring the quarter code.
And I'm like, I am next
for Killer Instinct.
He's like, no, you not.
Whatever.
Anyhow, early consoles in
arcades defined us as a culture
with video games.
And from then, we actually
branched out to PC gaming
and modern consoles.
We saw the rise of
the Super Nintendo
and the adoption in
the American culture.
And from there things
really got interesting,
when we started seeing the
adoption the early 2000s
with browser gaming,
social gaming,
and of course, the
boom of mobile game.
And really, that's
where we are right now.
When you look at the
history of gaming,
you actually see
these crests and peaks
in trends and fashions.
And it just keeps
and keeps going.
And where we are
today is mobile gaming
is a very, very mature market.
It's an extremely
mature ecosystem.
And working at Google,
working on games at Google,
the number one question
I get from people
is, what's the next big thing?
What should we be doing?
The ecosystem is very mature.
It's very saturated.
There's lots of competition, a
lot of great content out there.
But a lot of people are
wondering what's next.
And there's a lot of great
opportunity out there.
We've seen cloud
gaming become a thing.
Neural gaming, you know,
the little headsets
that you think about the color
green and all of a sudden you
can cast Expelliarmus
on somebody.
VR headsets-- has
anyone actually checked
out cardboard upstairs?
Round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
And the question is,
these all have opportunity
to really redefined how
humans interact with gaming.
But I got tell you something.
That when you add
them all together,
they still don't
equal the potential
of what's going to happen in the
next decade with the next five
billion gamers.
They don't even
come close when you
look at it from
this perspective.
You see, in 2014, we reached
about seven billion humans
on the planet.
Can I get a round of
applause for procreation?
[APPLAUSE]
You have no idea how
long I've been waiting
to get a round of applause
for humans breeding.
Yeah.
We had seven billion humans
on the planet in 2014.
By all estimates, about
two billion of those
are connected to the internet,
which leaves roughly about five
billion who do not have
internet connectivity.
Now if you look at the
trends of connectivity,
the way that industries are
moving, the way the funding is
working, the way that the
towers are being built,
the way devices are
being rolled out,
everyone pretty much
has the same estimate.
Which is, within
the next 10 years,
that five billion
humans are going
to become connected
to the internet.
In 10 years-- 2025--
we're going to get
the majority of
humanity coming online.
Think about that for a second.
It roughly took
us about 40 years
to get two billion
humans online.
And in 10 years, we're going
to get the next five billion.
We're talking about Harlem
Shake to a whole new level.
And of course, this has massive
implications for gaming.
Because when you talk about
who the next five billion are,
you have to look at
all the statistics
and realize where
they're coming from.
If you actually take
the majority of Japan
and the United States, and
look at their connectivity
saturation, we're pretty
much already saturated.
If 100% of these
countries came online,
we're not even
going to put a drop
in the bucket of the
next five billion humans.
We are highly saturated with
respect to connectivity.
However, if you look at the
lowly saturated countries,
like China and
India, you realize
that when you take population
plus connectivity--
see that rise in that graph?
You realize that these
low saturation areas
are where the next five billion
connected human beings are
going to be coming from.
And to put this in a little
bit more perspective,
let's look at the number
of mobile subscriptions
to date, right now.
So that previous slide showed
China at roughly about 45%
connectivity.
That represents 1.1 billion
connections on mobile devices.
In India, 12%
saturation represents
900 million connections.
And it's going up.
To put this in perspective
of Western game developers--
everyone in the
room right now who's
trying to make it big in these
markets-- the entire population
of the United States
is 317 million.
If you had every single human
being in the United States
download your game
right now, you still not
equal 1/3 of 12% of the
potential of these new markets.
That's the next five billion.
And the cool thing
is that they're not
going to go through
the same thing we did.
Right?
Like we all grew up with these
crummy laptops that basically
gave us face cancer
or something.
Right?
Anyone remember your
face getting hot
when you were
programming for too long?
Nobody?
That was just me?
OK.
That's probably why I'm bald.
But we had this
trend where we'd go
from some of the
clunky desktops to one
of the more powerful ones,
everyone's on laptops now.
No, these next five
billion human beings
are going to be able to
leapfrog that entire process
and actually jump
right to mobile.
Mobile is cheap.
Mobile is powerful.
The amount of power in
a single mobile device
rivals what we had
in the early 2000s.
And it's just going
to get better.
It's going to get cheaper.
Everyone saw in the
keynote yesterday
the amazing applications,
or the amazing devices
that are coming out at
really low cost that
are going to allow
these next five billion
human beings to come online
and get access to your gaming
content.
But of course this brings
in problems for Western game
developers that we don't
even get understand.
Here's the big one.
In India, about 20% of those
individuals speak English.
How many Western game
developers in here
actually speak more
than one language?
Round of applause?
Round of applause.
No, I can't see your hands.
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
So good.
Mainland China only 0.83%.
Now if you look
at the collection
in the majority
of game developers
in the Western market, they
all come from America--
these guys don't speak English.
When I see an
application show up
in my store that isn't in
a language I recognize,
I'm automatically
skeptical of it.
These individuals are going
to be acting the same way.
Now let's look at this.
Of the five billion
humans are connecting,
we need to consider who they
are, because that basically
defines their spending habits.
That defines how they're
going to interact
with the games in the
environment they were created.
So in the USA, you
have to consider
if we're 88% saturated, it's
roughly the 88 upper percentage
of wealthiest individuals who
have internet connectivity.
These are the individuals
who have the ability
to afford the devices and afford
the internet connection in such
a leisureship way that it
doesn't put too much strain
on their day-to-day operations.
Japan-- upper 75%.
China-- upper 45%.
India-- upper 12%.
What this means for
everyone in the audience
is your users-- the users, the
next five billion human beings
who are going to be coming
on looking for your game--
are not going to be coming from
the upper wealthiest echelons.
They're going to be
coming from the lowest.
This means that
you're going to have
to reconsider how you
define your purchasing,
your marketing, your
monetization strategies.
Because these people will not be
the ones who have 100% ability
to do In-App purchases
all the time.
This is a great
graph of connectivity
throughout the world.
You can see the darker
regions, the lighter regions.
Of course, this isn't
a conservative--
or an inclusive map, because
I couldn't get the resolution.
But you need to also consider
the next five billion
users are not going to be
coming on from the areas that
are already massively connected.
They're going to be coming
from the regions that
are not yet connected.
Because again, if you look
at that previous slide,
and we talk about
wealth and distribution
and where these
people are, they're
not going to be in the
major metropolitan cities.
They're going to be
right outside of that.
When you look at the cost
distribution of where
you can actually afford
to live, and it's
going to slowly expand out.
Your users are
going to be in areas
that are developing
connectivity.
And this is kind of
good and kind of bad.
But the problem is we don't
know what kind of connectivity
we'll have.
Most people consider
that when you
start in an urban
environment, you should really
have the best
connectivity, right?
There's the most
economic funding there.
You're able to build
the biggest cell towers.
And as you move towards
more sparsely dense areas,
you get a worse connection
at first, and then over time,
they build it up.
But a lot of
countries are actually
leapfrogging this process.
Their established infrastructure
in metropolitan areas
actually keep them from
advancing connectivity
to a point that they
can actually get 4G
and beyond connected networks.
So if it's too populated, or
there's too many buildings,
or there's too much
ancient architecture,
they can't actually build
the cell towers there.
In retrospect, or in conflict
with that, because there's
so much opportunity to
build these cell towers out
in the emerging
areas, we can actually
get 4G and 5G connectivity.
So this means that the
five billion people who
are coming from the
lower economic areas
have better connectivity
than the people getting
paid the most money living
in metropolitan areas.
Which is a little weird.
The takeaway from
this is that you
have no idea what
the connectivity
of these individuals
is going to be.
Half of them could be sitting
in an inner city suburbanite
with 2G connectivity because
they can't get anything better,
basically having to hop from
Wi-Fi spot to Wi-Fi spot
to get anything done.
Or they may be out
in the rural areas
with a full 4G connectivity,
but a device that
can't run anything
more than a calculator.
So with all this in mind,
you're game developers, right?
Round of applause if
you're a game developer.
[APPLAUSE]
Just so I know what
not to say next.
Round of applause if
you're from press.
[NO APPLAUSE]
OK, good.
We can talk about cool stuff.
So let's talk about what
you guys need to do.
So with all this in
your mind, hopefully
you're getting a picture of
who the next five billion are
and what this means for
you as a game developer.
Let's talk about what you have
to do to actually influence
this market and be competitive
in this environment.
So the first off is
localization matters, period.
There's no debate to this.
You have no wiggle room
to discuss localization.
You can't-- this is
all that matters.
You have to understand that
the movement between language
as a communication as the human
brain understands the world
and perceives the
things around it
is based in our fundamental
knowledge in teaching
of language.
How many people in here actually
bought JRPGs for the Dreamcast
and spent the first 30
hours trying to figure out
what the game actually was
about because you couldn't
read any of the Japanese?
Anybody?
Round of applause?
[APPLAUSE]
Right?
Imagine that for the
next five billion gamers.
They're not going
to put up with it.
Right?
They expect stuff in
their local language.
They're going to want to
experience your content
in their local language so they
can feel more immersed with it,
have a deeper
connection with it.
This is such an
important problem
that Google actually knows
that this is a huge problem.
We actually have a
website dedicated
to entire resources for
internationalization.
Visit this URL here.
We've got 20 different tools
and products and layouts
to help you figure out how to
localize your content better.
In fact, one of my favorite ones
is a pseudo-localization tool.
You can actually run your
application through this
and it'll change your
fonts and actually show you
where your UI fails with
different languages.
So I know it's a little hard
to see on the big screen,
but you can see some of the
icons start getting clipped.
You can see things become
unreadable over time.
At least bare minimum, actually
seeing how your app and your UI
looks when you put it in
Mandarin versus English,
it changes the way you
actually approach the game
and how your UI
should be laid out.
And in fact, this is so
important that on Google Play,
we have a very simple
three-step process.
We have a button.
You just click the
button and we'll
do half of the work for you.
Right?
You click this, you fill out
a couple things and boom,
your game will get translated.
That's how important
localization
is for the next
five billion people.
We don't want you
to just make a game,
we want you to
make a global game.
We want you to make
an impactful game.
We want you to make a
game that changes people's
lives at a global level.
But this has absolutely nothing
to do with the larger concern
here, which is that
localization is not
equal to culturalization.
Can anyone tell me what's
wrong with this picture?
Take a second and look it.
I know we were all partying
last night, it's all right.
AUDIENCE: They're all violent.
COLT MCANLIS: Perhaps.
The problem is that
the majority of these
are actually Anglo-Saxon based.
Dragons, kings, princesses,
knights, honor, swords,
round tables, chivalry.
These are themes
and lore that we,
in the Anglo-Saxon descendants
in Western America and Europe,
we grew up on this.
We know who King Arthur is.
He's part of our linear.
He's part of our stories
that we tell ourselves.
But individuals growing
up in China and in India
have no idea who the
hell King Arthur is.
They grew up with a different
lore, a different way
to describe themselves
and represent themselves
in society.
Where we grew up
with Lancelot, they
grew up with "Romance
of the Three Kingdoms."
These types of
environments actually
allow us to connect
with the content
at a very important level.
Here's a great case study.
There's a game called Ski Safari
who, a while ago, actually put
out this information.
Mildly successful in
English-speaking countries
in Europe and America,
and they wanted
to actually enter
the Chinese market.
And so they actually put their
game out pretty much as is,
with minor localization.
The game really didn't do well.
I mean, we're talking maybe
1% to 2% average conversion
over a six-week period.
They decided to
throw the long ball
and go for complete
culturalization.
They touched everything.
What had previously looked like
northern peaks in Switzerland,
they actually changed
it all to look
like a winter in
the Chinese hills.
The result was staggering.
60 x increase in monetization.
The reason was because
the individuals
felt compelled and
connected to the content.
It felt like the
stories they knew,
the environment that
they were familiar with.
Right?
While we all know
knights storming a castle
and pouring tar
on people, that's
not represented in
these other cultures.
Culturalization
of your content is
more important than just
simply localizing it.
Of course, this brings
us to the next thing,
which is that you actually
need to monetize everybody,
everything, all parts
of all processes, right?
The reason for this is
that how these countries--
the purchasing habits
is vastly different.
In China, you have to understand
that there is a boom right now.
There's a surge of
credit card companies.
Credit cards are the big
competing market in China
right now.
There are more people that
can issue you a credit card
than there are companies
to sell you a cell phone.
This is a big industry
right now in China.
And as you can see, if
you look at the trends,
it's actually growing.
About 23% of all
individuals in China
have a credit card right now.
Take this in contrast to India,
where it's only about 1.8%.
Now their industry is growing,
but it's not necessarily
that same rate.
As the next five billion humans
come online in the next 10
years, they're not going
to be doing it the same way
because the infrastructure
isn't keeping up.
It means a lot of
these individuals who
are coming online
are not going to be
able to have that direct
In-App purchaseability.
Which means you as
a developer need
to understand that
and start figuring out
how to monetize these 900
million users who may not
be purchasing with
credit cards, right?
Let's go back to look at the
income versus connectivity
versus population.
This effectively means that
the wealthiest individuals
in an area who are
connected and are gaming
are going to be the ones who
are most likely to do In-App
purchases, because they have
the ability and access to credit
cards.
Everybody else most
likely is going
to be best monetized with ads.
Look at that for India.
The majority of
the ability for you
to monetize your Indian
audience is actually
going to come from
advertisements, not necessarily
In-App purchases.
These are individuals
who we've already
seen in studies are more willing
to watch a five-minute YouTube
clip advertising something
than actually enter credit card
numbers to buy a
temporary power-up.
Now a lot of game developers
would immediately just discount
this entire market for that,
because you've built yourselves
up to be an In-App purchasing
environment because that's
how the most Western
markets work.
But that shouldn't
be your strategy.
Right?
Typically this is the
way that game developers
are working right now.
We have some build
of our application,
we upload it to the Cloud
and it goes out to a device.
And what happens on that
device stays on that device.
And if we want to do AB
testing or something else,
we basically have to
reissue our packages.
But that can't work that way
with the next five billion
human beings.
You see, we need the ability
to upload an APK or game,
and have it actually
change and modify,
and basically respond to the
individual in the environment
that's actually monetizing
to it a way that
doesn't put too much strain
on us as game developers.
We don't want to build 90
different versions of our game.
Who's got time-- ain't
nobody got time for that.
That was my one meme.
You guys got one meme
out of me tonight.
Basically, this is how you
want something to work right.
So your APK is out in the
wild-- it's out with the phone
and you upload some
changes to your settings.
You upload a new German pack
or some monetization settings
to see whether or
not individuals
will click the blue button
more to buy the red boots,
and how that is
different between Germany
versus India versus Mongolia.
Then you want some application
to boot up and actually say,
hey, I am in Mongolia, please
give me the Mongolia-specific
data, and it comes down.
This is a really big
process to build and to do.
Well, the good news is Google's
already thought of that.
We have something called
Google Tag Manager.
Round of applause if you've
heard of this before.
[APPLAUSE]
Nice.
Now those people-- round of
applause if you're using it.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
That was, for you on the camera
back there, that was roughly
about a 10% to 2% drop.
Right there.
Google Tag Manager is a
technology that effectively
allows you-- it's a client-side
tech and a cloud tech that
basically allows
you to say, hey, I'm
going to upload a bunch of
different name value settings
in pairs and data files that
represent different builds
and configurations of my game
depending on these parameters.
And as phones basically boot
up and provide their statistics
to the Cloud-based
resource, they
will get specifically the name
value pairs and the information
that you provided for it.
And the cool thing
is you can keep
doing this on a daily
basis and the user never
has to re-download the APK.
They just get your JSON
setting files-- well,
hyper-compressed
JSON session files.
This is really nice,
because this effectively
means if you do your
game the right way,
you can put settings
in there that
allow you to monetize people
differently without drastically
having to change your build.
A skew in China can actually
start offering people
more In-App purchases if you
notice that their ability
to view ads is
actually diminished.
Versus in India,
you can actually
start them with ads as a
primary viewing mechanism.
And then over time, if you
see that their behavior starts
changing to In-App
purchases, you
can modify the entire behavior
of your app with Google Tag
Manager without having
to reissue the APK.
Because again, we're
talking about connectivity,
we're talking about lower
echelons of economic ladders
here.
Maybe these people
don't have the money
to actually pay for bits
to get down on the wire.
So AB testing gets
really difficult.
This actually brings me to
a really touchy subject.
So I don't know if
you guys have seen
my videos on Compressor Head.
Compressor Head?
Round of applause if you've
seen Compressor Head?
[APPLAUSE]
So that's like four people.
OK.
Everybody go watch
Compressor Head.
It's a bald man rambling
about compression algorithms.
So here's my second
meme for the day.
Your apps are too big and you
should feel bad about that.
Period.
Everyone in here-- if you're
making a game right now,
your game is too big and you
should feel bad in your heart
about what you're doing.
Here's why.
I wanted to figure out what the
hell was going on in the gaming
ecosystem on Google Play.
I wanted to figure out
why our games were so long
and why they took
so long to download.
So I actually downloaded
a large majority of them
and start doing
analysis on our games.
What I found out was
that the top free game
was roughly about
34 megs in size.
The top paid game, 125 megs.
That's huge for a mobile game.
Right?
The limit is how are people
using extension packs?
There's a lot of content there.
Let's put this in perspective.
If you're running on
a 1G or 2G connection,
that's about three minutes
to download a free game.
So a lot of the free
developers nowadays,
they pay a lot of money
for user acquisition
to click on an ad to go to
the page to then download
their application to
hope to get a conversion
and they're adding three
minutes into the middle
that pipeline for the user
just to get your bits.
You can see a
sudden drop off when
you-- how many people
in here have done that?
When you're like, oh, I'm
going to download this game,
and then you forget about it.
And five days later
you're like, when
the hell did I
install this game?
Round of applause,
please, please.
[APPLAUSE]
Everyone developing
games, look around.
Those are you're constituents.
These are the people who
are having this problem.
And for 125 megs, that's
a ten-minute download.
Who's got time for 10 minutes?
This is the 2000s man, come on.
I got to give a talk
and then go walk around
with cardboard
strapped on my face.
So I decided to dig
in a little bit more
because I was a little
bit upset about this.
I wanted to figure out where the
bloat was actually coming from.
So I open up all of these
APKs and did analysis.
And what I saw was
actually really
embarrassing and striking to me.
What I saw here is--
you can see this
is a breakdown of content--
and the number one
contributor to size was
actually image data.
By a majority of factor.
We're looking at easily
roughly about 50% of all APKs
is just image data.
If you dig in a little
bit deeper with this,
you can actually see that
it's majorally PNG files.
75% of all the image
data is PNG files.
Now for those you who don't
understand PNG as a technology,
PNG is an image format
that's only lossless.
Which means it's not actually
reducing any of the procedural
or the perceptive
bits of information
to actually get
larger compression.
Other formats like JPEG
and or GIFF or JIFF--
depending on what
side of a fence
you're on on that
one-- or GPU formats
actually taken into account
lossy versions of this.
They'll effectively reduce
the amount of color space
that the human eye
can discern in order
to take advantage
of compression.
And that's why those file
formats are so small.
PNG does no such thing.
Which means the best
you can absolutely
hope for it maybe 50%?
60%, if you're lucky.
If you've got a
full black image,
maybe you can get
down lower than that?
PNG is not what you
should be using.
These are devices in their
pockets with powerful GPUs.
And if you notice
up there, the GPU--
that's the blue mark-- the GPUs
is actually one of the smallest
used in there.
GPU textures are really
what you should be using.
This is what I hoped to see,
which was the majority was GPU
and the minority was PNG.
And here's why.
GPU textures compress
smaller than PNGs,
which means that not only
is your distribution size
is going to be smaller,
but your GPU residency size
is going to be smaller.
That's something you
have to understand
about PNG and JPEG
and GIFF formats.
Is while they transmit small
during your distribution,
they have to be
inflated to full 32 bits
per pixel when their
resident on your GPU.
If a user has one
or two games open
and they're all conflicting
for space using 32-bit,
fully inflated textures?
That's a lot.
Think of it this way--
a 10kx10k texture
atlas at 32 bits per
pixel is four megs.
For 256 meg devices that
are strapped to your face
or to your wrist, that's
a lot of residency.
Let's put this in a much
different perspective.
OK, so let's take this little
256x256 image of a parrot face.
Everyone likes parrots?
Cool.
The PNG size for
this on disk-- this
is the distribution size
of 107k-- the GPU memory--
so the inflated version is 192k.
I want to put this in contrast
with the GPU formats--
so DXT1, PVR and ETC.
You can easily see
that their disk size
is equal to their
GPU residency size.
But here's the striking part.
If you add all three of these
together, it's only 80k.
So if you were to actually
take your PNG file
and compress it in
DXT, PVR and ETC
and ship that instead
of the PNG file,
it still would be 50% smaller
in GPU residency and 20% smaller
in disk distribution.
Please use
GPU-formatted textures.
If you do nothing else from
this talk besides this rambling
guy who was talking about
people in India and China,
walk away from this knowing that
the first thing you need to do
is investigate how to get
GPU-formatted textures
into your pipeline.
Because individuals
in these areas
are going to be downloading your
content with restricted devices
with smaller bandwidth, with
higher connectivity costs.
And this is going to be
the main thing that's
going to give you the
ability to breach that.
So here's the deal.
We don't know
what's next, right?
I can stand up here.
I can predict it.
I'm wrong, no matter
what, no matter what I say
is the next big thing.
I can say it's a device.
I can say it's grass
blowing in the winter,
or some robotic butterfly
that can make you coffee.
It doesn't matter.
The next big thing is unknown.
It could be a new
bird-based game,
where you're throwing
birds at other birds.
I don't even know.
Every bird game seems
to be a big thing.
It could be a new
technology that people
strap to their
faces, or give them
a better understanding of
the environment at hand.
We don't know what the next big
technology or the next big fad
is.
But we know that in
the next 10 years,
five billion human beings are
going to be coming online.
And they're going to be gamers.
Because that is what we
do as a human species.
We play games.
It's something that
has changed my life
and the lives of many of
the people in this room.
And you have to understand that
when these five billion humans
come online for the
first time and they
get that device their hand
and they play that first game,
it is going to
change their lives.
Just like it did some
bald kid growing up
in the Las Vegas desert.
Your job as game
developers is to make sure
that that game that changes
their lives is yours.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
Thank you for your time.
Go build something great.
[APPLAUSE]